bien merci l'élection présidentielle
vient d'avoir lieu nous avons un nouveau
président de la république et de
quinquennat qui s'ouvre doit être une
réussite si c'était un échec
le quinquennat en l'occurrence ce serait
les français qui en paiera les pots
cassés
et cette réussite c'est l'objet du
travail que nous avons fait au cours des
quinze derniers jours depuis notre
défaite au premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle elle doit dépendre de
notre point de vue du projet que nous
pouvons apporter à la france et aux
français ce projet île à françois baroin
et bernard acoyer l'a dit lundi il a été
retravaillé
il a été retravaillé pour prendre en
compte ce qu'ont dit les français lors
de l'élection présidentielle et pour
permettre je crois de lui donner à la
fois plus d'ambition et plus d'équité
plus d'ambition en tout cas que celui
qui est porté par notre président de la
république parce qu'il y a besoin de
réformes qui ne soit pas floues mais qui
permettent de rouvrir le marché du
travail en france de reconstruire un
ascenseur éducatif de faire en sorte que
l'europe se rebaptise en se fondant sur
l'essentiel et pas sur l'accessoire
qu'elle s'occupe des granges enjeux
stratégiques et pas de norme tout à fait
secondaire est de faire en sorte qu'on
rétablisse et je reconnais que dans
cette campagne s'est passé
malheureusement trop inaperçu qu'on
rétablisse l'autorité de l'état qui est
la garantie pour les français à la fois
de leur sécurité et de la justice mais
également un projet qui est plus
équitable ou la défense du pouvoir
d'achat la protection des plus faibles
la capacité des salariés notamment des
salariés les plus modestes à retrouver
des marges de manoeuvre à travers on le
verra tout à l'heure la défiscalisation
des heures supplémentaires par exemple
la baisse de l'impôt sur le revenu bref
une capacité à dire aux français bien
sûr que notre pays pour retrouver ses
ambitions doit faire un certain nombre
d'efforts et de transformation mais ces
efforts doivent être équitablement
répartis et c'est l'engagement que dans
la plateforme udi les républicains nous
souhaitons prendre
et puis sur les débats qui sont en cours
moi je veux faire deux observations la
première des choses c'est que j'entends
parler de recomposition politique et la
recomposition politique ce n'est jamais
une démarche individuelle c'est une
démarche collective et il n'y a pas de
démarche collective dans ce convoi
on a beaucoup de discours sur la
recomposition mais uniquement des
tentatives de captage individuel je le
dis comme je le pense
or refonder la vie politique française
ça ne peut pas passer par de vieilles
pratiques qui sont en réalité la
proposition de placer deux postes
oubliant nos idées si nous avons perdu
l'élection présidentielle nous n'avons
perdu ni nos idées nos valeurs ni nos
projets c'est ce que nous devons
présenter ensemble aux français je le
dis d'autant plus que je suis frappée
depuis hier par un discours qui paraît
de la part du mouvement du président de
la république très ouvert mais qui en
réalité se traduit par une fermeture
assez grande je veux le souligner
laventure ou la mésaventure de manuel
valls hier montre une réaction brutale à
quelqu'un qui manifestement avait envie
de travailler avec le nouveau président
de la république je pense que ça doit
servir de leçon
abandonner ses idées abandonné sa
formation
c'est en réalité le mée revivre le
meilleur moyen de se faire claquer la
porte au nez et d'éviter la
recomposition politique dont tout le
monde parle cette recomposition elle
aura ou pas lieu en fonction du vote des
français soit ils choisissent de donner
à lui dit et républicains une majorité
et nous aurons un travail constructif à
faire en direction des français aux
côtés du nouveau président de la
république soit ils choisissent de lui
signer un chèque en blanc
et ça n'a jamais fonctionné soit ils
choisissent qu'une majorité relative se
dessine et à ce moment là il faudra que
lui dit les républicains et l'ensemble
des forces politiques en tire les
conséquences
mais je trouve assez comment dirais-je
invraisemblable de vouloir zapper le
débat législatif
je terminerai par là le débat
présidentiel et on le regardait tout à
l'heure dans une analyse de l'opinion
n'a pas eu lieu
sur le fond et sur les valeurs
il ya une frustration aujourd'hui c'est
nos concitoyens de savoir comment on
traite les sujets de chômage de la
sécurité de l'éducation de la protection
sociale de la couverture médicale et
c'est le débat que nous devons ouvrir
avec enthousiasme au cours de cette
élection de façon répétée respectueuse
de toutes les forces politiques et comme
le disait bernard acoyer au moment où
tout le monde est instable
nous nous voulons cette stabilité une
stabilité qui permet aux français de
parler de ce que nous allons changer
pour eux demain et non pas seulement de
parler comme beaucoup de même de ce
qu'ils veulent occuper comme
responsabilités ça c'est un sujet qui
est totalement déplacée aujourd'hui nous
commençons à construire
nous le souhaitons une majorité pour la
france cette majorité elle se fait dans
l'unité elle se fait dans un projet
rénover plus ambitieux et plus équitable
est sévère les français maintenant que
nous allons nous tourner pour qu'ils
décident s'ils nous confie la majorité
on sait qui va présider la france la
question de la législative c'est de
savoir qui valent à gouverner